Хто найбагатший?
Україна! Україна!
Тільки одне можу Вам сказати.
Ці цигани не займаються ніяким цим...
Ці цигани їдять на заробітки в Росію.
Всі працюють.
Ці сигаретами не займаються, наркотиками
не займаються, зброєю не займаються.
Я знаю всю Закарпатську область і всю Україну.
Я всюди їздив, я все знаю.
До мене приходять люди, щоб я допоміг то те, то се.
Я за цих циганів відповідаю.
Бідним допомагає. Дахи допомагає будувати,
будівельними матеріалами.
Ми теж допоможемо, працьовиті.
Працюємо.
Я думаю, що кожен українець допоможе.
Ми — їхні люди. Хоч і цигани.
Ми — громадяни України. Ні?!
Звичайно!
Маємо право на допомогу. Ні? Державну
Є і такі, що не можуть ні писати, ні читати. Але є, розумієш...
Треба було звертати увагу не тільки на український народ,
а й на інших людей, тому що...
Візьмемо Тячівський район.
Там дійсно є близько 150 циганів з дітьми.
Бачили, де вони живуть. Це жах!
Так як в Китаї. Ви самі бачили, не треба казати.
Індія, Китай... Там точно так, як і вони.
Хоча, є місця, а не виділяють їх.
А по ідеї, мали б розподіляти місця
між українцями і циганами.
Як бачить, що українець піднімається,
і він б старався підійматися.
Щоб був розвиток між народами.
А я — музикант. На весіллях граю, старостую деколи.
На запросинах граю, група в мене є.
[співає пісню під гітару]
Ми вже тепер, можна сказати, роми, но ми все одно...
До речі, «цигани» — це лише слово, кличка.
У 1999 році вийшла наша перша ромська книга,
яка вийшла в Ужгороді.
Там доказано, що прийняли нашу діаспору, ромську.
І навіть герб наш ромський.
Це велике слово для нашої національності,
що признали наш герб і нашу національність.
І через це відтоді пішло слово «ром».
Що вже не цигани, а роми.
А це просто кличка. Наприклад, циган.
Як ми на вас кажемо «ґаджов» чи «русин».
[співає пісню під гітару]
Ті самі, можна сказати, біженці.
У прямому значенні.
Ми — біженці, через релігію.
Ми були ліниві у релігії.
Бо по сьогодні є велике ідолопоклонство...
Адам, Адам... Як його звали?
Забув як його звали.
Адам у 1442–1443 році зібрав ромську діаспору,
і вирушили у вигнання в Італію і на іспанські землі.
І то пішло таке вигнання, що ми — розділений народ,
бо чуємо, що і там ром, і там, і там...
Коли Монголо-Татарська навала була,
тоді велике вигнання було.
Тоді всі були змішані.
Були і цигани, і українці, і росіяни.
І, що сьогодні цікаво — чому ми бачимо на Закарпатті
і смуглих, і білих, і майже жовтих?
Та який ти, каже, циган? А він ще чорніший за мене.
А  він — українець. В паспорті — українець.
Розказує біографію, доказує, що він — українець.
А я стану біля нього і ми з ним однакові.
Як мій от зять. Ну докажи, що він українець,
якщо він ще чорніший за цигана.
То який ти циган чи який ти українець?
Це не секрет, тоді дуже пішло змішування крові.
Зате ми сьогодні бачимо,
що і румуни є, і угорці, і волохи та інші.
Історія наша прекрасна і чиста.
Чим? Тим чиста, бо ми люди такі.
Стараємось бути чистими до людей,
до ближнього насамперед.
Друге тим, що наша національність, наш народ,
стараємось тільки тоді бути недобрими,
коли нас недолюблюють.
Чи коли до нас в прямому значенні задираються.
Просто, що ти більш чорний, а ти більш білий.
Буває таке, нацизм, як ми кажем по-нашому.
І тут саме описується — «Про циган».
І, будь ласка, тут моє фото, моя біографія.
Я вчився на диякона.
Був час такий. Після дитбудинку я пішов вчитися.
Втратив усі надії і пішов вчитися.
І не прийняли тоже, через національність.
Пішов до владики, щоб отримати
благословіння, а він каже:
«Я тебе прекрасно розумію.
А мене хто зрозуміє, що взяв цигана в церкву».
Питає: «Ти згідний?»
Згідний.
Скільки тут дітей!
Ти мовчи.
От! Один чорний!
От! Один також білий!
Найбіліший!
Я сивий. Я побриюся і буду білий.
Ану ти покажи свої..
Що цигани їдять?
Борщі, м'ясо...
Циганські страви — картопля і м'ясо.
Ви тут постійно готуєте?
В річці зараз постійно? Тепло.
Машинка пере.
Просто не маю шнура такого великого.
Кажу, що купаються зараз часто, бо тепло.
Це все ваші діти, так?
Так, семеро.
Нічого собі.